okay I didn't expect this to start here
for reference I loved resident evil I
played very little of three because I
didn't care for it the first time that I
played it for whatever reason so I know
like very very little about this game
nice and rainy outside you got some CDs
what kind of CDs you got fan oh that's
well that's blurry very under toasted
white toast you could do better than
that come on Jesus Christ Jill also this
makes us seem like she's really short
how big is this table
this [ __ ] got some cleaning to do let's
see some magic yeah okay
I didn't expect any of this hey did we
wake up in an apartment when you know
how to actually make toast
Jesus the pizza guy I don't want to be
on a run immediately are you kidding
ah rub no no no no this isn't happening
I don't want anything to do with it come
on get out of here you're gonna be just
fine no likes well no they just love
that kind of thing yeah that'll that'll
help oh it did sorry oh my god why is
this so happening so immediately I'm
trying to update my life settings
because it says I play goob and I bet he
shut up again Jesus what is that
why have we done this I don't think
you're safe Joel I don't feel well now
that's convenient I get that that's a
video game language of telling me that
something has stopped but he could just
bust through any wall at any point in
time we have just established this this
is really pretty
who are you you call this a run this is
a brisk job Jesus go to the gym she does
have a nice butt though you didn't see
the man why is he suddenly shocked like
they would have banned a halt I was
heading into BA Jack gonna grab a pint
wait till this all blows over can I get
any of you [ __ ] I drink did I just
abandon him Wow okay okay okay this
seems fine everything's fine I don't
like any of that zombies main weakness
is just a Y offense okay that's right
okay well I see that great really no no
no no no no damn it I don't like any of
this
let's get we got it what are you sitting
here for we got to get out of here
that was cool I don't believe that
worked
my whole objective so far has been to
get to that roof and I did that so now
what hope so
we've been bringing survivors here here
where my guys have converted some subway
cars into a shelter okay
it's safe I'm with the umbrella
biohazard countermeasure service uvcs
for short are you kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me you guys are
the ones who caused all this
whoa whoa what are you talking about you
don't have to trust me but I'm going to
strange interaction coming yes you look
like you just slapped her he just went
smack on the back of her head most of
the hundred thousand civilians will wind
up dead
correction Undead nice we can have a cue
maybe we can go back to Russia yep but
we need help my men cannot do this alone
well unfortunately I have a giant
invincible man tailing me so I don't
know that you actually want me here
all right I'm going up to the street can
I take a gun with me I would like this
guy steal it with my feet
no alrighty then
but y'all ready from Carlos I reached me
I'm so worried that he's gonna show up
again
you mean the alley that's on fire what
does that mean hello hi how's everybody
doing oh shoot you in the face three
times I think four times no okay okay
they fall on the boat Erbs up are you
serious ah should have stabbed him while
I was down you better you better stay
down son that's a hose telling me this
[ __ ] is gonna pick that up how do you
have room in your pockets for that got a
shotgun things yourself cut the chain
cut chains yet fam nice to know it's
there though he [ __ ] himself that's
brown that's not blood that is brown
liquid right no oh that was close hahaha
okay
now yes that's not what I expected at
all I thought it would be something that
went on the top not pose
how to cheat you didn't even interact
with anything Joe how did you turn it
all off all on there you are bolt
cutters been looking for you for a while
thank you so we just want to shoot Oh Oh
- Oh does a dog's we don't like dogs we
don't like dogs boom I don't want it
electrocute dog stud oh this feels so
mean oh no oh I'm so sorry [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] do I have to stop a dog is that we
gonna make me stab a Doberman
I can't I can't really oh my god how do
you move so much oh you don't shoot them
in the head that's worth noting to some
be dog sure you don't have to be
headshot it all right
pawn open that yet you look like an
[ __ ]
what's a hole she got that but he might
be just actually dead I don't know man
he got scared it's fine fine thanks fine
why are you doing this so slowly Jill
come on hello I wasn't looking I was
looking at the box thank God
those spiders that's [ __ ] up dude you
should get that checked out that's
probably that's gonna that's gonna hurt
you in the long run open it oh cool it's
that does it one time you sewing me okay
is this gonna be difficult it's one time
he's only did they break or is it still
that no okay
oh why did you have to come so hard oh
my god I didn't if I had known now would
have happened I would you dude
[ __ ] that's a butthole if ever I've seen
one chill okay let's try this it did
work okay oh god oh my god oh my god
okay do a [ __ ] [ __ ] you dude [ __ ] you
go god you know what I'd say I tell you
my mind I'm going to get the shotgun
I don't i hate's why this so much
they're all that sound design I forgot
how much of a wimp I was I was like it's
gonna be fine gonna stream some resident
evil gonna play Resident Evil 3
everything's gonna be great I can't wait
I love puzzles and also I love the level
design in these games it's gonna be a
good time it was not you know this
brilliant get in here cool I know the
fancy box I love those I think oh my god
you guys it's a toilet paper look at
them it's
that's like 12 whole rolls pristine
toilet paper my god I haven't seen that
in months can you believe it just laying
that may be good all right Thank You m3
shotgun I will take it you out here
nemesis no no not him someone else
that's fine you can come in here I don't
care about you this I don't want to do
this I don't want to do it I hate
spiders so much probably gonna be fine
right like I'm probably gonna be just
like totally okay [ __ ] you know well
that is very handy and I'm very glad I
went back for it can't get through to
there I'm gonna keep going this way
everything's great everything's doing
great we're doing great we're doing
great I hear noises
I can hear you [ __ ] off [ __ ] off come
back here you punk [ __ ] [ __ ] this sucks
oh my god this audio oh my god how
nightmarish [ __ ] you dude why would you
even chase me slowly like why do they
retreat should've done that
oh my I saw you you [ __ ] turd that
was like a quite a noscope we just
pulled there okay is that it no I
swapped by accident okay wait that's
what you want
okay really [ __ ] I didn't think it what
no no you don't we don't have any hubs
but I did see hubs in this area we will
figure it out
who made the spiders stealthy please
please
oh thank off okay that's fine who could
who cares am i right this way
oh god I'm so sorry Jill Stu knew he's
gonna come out of it I bet he did it but
he went away oh okay a pothole oh I can
still hear them [ __ ] hell I hate this
so much
stop it stop it stop it [ __ ] oh I have
to go can I go straight ahead I agree I
agree totally agree Jill just get out no
map okay it's straight that's just
straight its straight
it's straight it's super straight no you
don't know you don't know you don't know
you don't get me out of butt holes by to
[ __ ] bill immediately good thing they
can't pass through that gate I think
yeah I've already been there easy
how we doing not right
it's this way confused about why that
appears gray on the map it just seems
really weird to me but yeah we all look
hey all right okay
cool okay great well at least he walks
slowly
it's fine it's work we don't need to
hang out wait what were you doing in
there
reading books please go away please go
away oh my god I would like to leave oh
I don't want to deal with any of you no
no no you why are we making a phone call
right now he's literally right back
this is the worse just the worst also
you [ __ ] all came back
oh my god so much but [ __ ] Joe Joe I
wish you would run he could do that
that's not fair that's not fair at all
Joe just move faster just move faster
move faster both of you can [ __ ] off
no I don't have time wait dodging didn't
what okay here we go
all right the music Scheldt
which is suspicious I understand are a
three SS Carlos we did it um okay I
don't want to get lost out here because
[ __ ] boys hey oh that's me
that's a waste I have to shoot right in
the middle of it Oh God
oh why have you added that to the
already harrowing [ __ ] experience of
this [ __ ] stick of a game okay where do
we need to go it's all the way down here
isn't it he's gonna show back up it's
fine we're gonna go out fest - run
you give me a nice hat Oh God this poor
woman okay let's take this he's right oh
I'm right in the face with that one damn
dude
she's gonna jump in front of me again
what is you also have stinky breath
he's stanky also [ __ ] hell this is
nots oh my god chill you're so slow
you're the slowest video game character
in the [ __ ] world am I going the
right way am I going the right way am I
going the right way I think I am I think
I am I think I am [ __ ] off [ __ ] off dude
[ __ ] that's not fair that's not a start
no okay Dutch Dutch Dutch Dutch Dutch go
through this [ __ ] door please please
nope
don't get caught on a tree now it's not
the time you shouldn't be here either
dodj bye oh god I'm just so panicked I'm
just so panicked oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god are you
kidding no whoa that was very lucky dogs
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
get me he's just he's he could get
through wolves we've seen him do it
already I don't feel safe here I know
that you think that I should because the
music stopped
but what video game ass video game logic
is that
oh come on not again
why aren't we just getting on the train
anyway I didn't realize he was that hot
on me that quickly oh [ __ ] Jill I hate
you for this I really hate you for this
thank God that doesn't stun me
it's very intense music we need him to
come to here no I don't deal with that
later
hey [ __ ] pick up that case he
dropped again well why is he standing
this time I don't like that I just want
to get this ammo just stay down let me
just grab this please Jill you got to
pull through here you got it you got to
do it you got to get it done
it's probably too small to get through
them right now the music still bad the
things are not getting better now is it
gonna chill out
[Music]
Carlos do you copy I'm really mad at
this [ __ ]